okay members are going to be starting in
about 30 seconds
okay members we're going to be starting
the meeting now um so good evening
everybody and uh welcome to this meeting
of the governance and audit committee
um there's a little bit of a blurb I've
got to read out before so you've all
heard it before but I'm afraid you have
to hear it again
um fire alarm evacuation procedure the
fire alarm is activated vacate the
office via the stairs please do not use
the lift assemble in holy Square on the
green and officers will assist you and
advise you when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber uh filming does
anyone intend to film the meeting
I hope that makes things easier any
member of the public who objects to the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting
um restriction on the use of mobile
phones with everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they're not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting meeting is
going to be live streamed for members of
the public it will be recorded and will
be subsequently broadcast on the
council's YouTube channel and I wonder
how many hits it's going to get yeah
um I have been notified that there's one
member wishing to speak under 20.1 and
that's councilor Yates on agenda items
five and nine I don't think we have
anyone else present who wishes to speak
under that
um
I'll just let um advise members that
because we have somebody wanting to
speak
um the request has been made could we
deal with agenda items five and nine
earlier which I've accepted so we are
going to be jumping around a bit on the
agenda uh it will be one two three five
nine four six seven eight but stick with
me we'll do it together it's gonna be
fine
um in terms of apologies for absence
we've been notified that councilor
manners is unavailable and being
substituted by councilor Davis and we've
had apologies from councilor Braidwood
is there anybody else who would like to
put in apologies
I know that councilor packman is coming
and just running late so there's no
apologies there
nope
okay agenda item two Declarations of
interest is anybody got any interest
they would like to declare councilor
Davis
uh I'd just like clarification Sheriff I
could which I did mention to you earlier
uh within the reports it refers to both
four and five and the fact that there's
an objection to the item that's still
outstanding with the external Auditors I
was one of the authors of the complaints
of the Auditors originally I don't
believe it has any implications but
maybe if I could have a
monetary officer Samira
as far as I'm concerned there's no
conflict at the moment but if his comes
to a vote then perhaps at that point you
can leave the meeting
thank you very much
okay thank you very much so agenda item
three minutes of the meeting held on the
26th of July 2023 uh before we go
forward to approve the minutes there's a
couple of changes I'd like to make
people aware of and then some updates I
think it's important to Just note
um from the minutes last time
um so at the last meeting held on the
26th of July during item 8 the annual
governance statement 2022-23 it was
stated that over the 27 complaints
received by the Ombudsman one of the
complaints was upheld the correct number
of upheld complaints was 12. I mean that
was just a an error it was in the report
I think the number was going over two
pages if I understand it
um and the second one that on item six
of the minutes it stated that members
requested the head of property to attend
a future governance in order committee
to discuss the process of generating
income with the council's at least
leasehold housing stock however that
should have said council's portfolio
properties and not just specific to
housing
um I have some updates for members from
actions and things requested from the
last meeting which I will just quickly
flick through
um if you can in page eight of the
report it was requested that
um Dan Evans
um attend the meeting as the
um uh the head of ICT I can confirm that
he has been invited to the next meeting
and that will align with when we're
expecting the internal audit report as
well for that area so that is in
progress
um
the the matter I've just talked about
with the incorrect reference to housing
in the minutes I have met with
um officers and we believe that the
matter raised around property income is
probably a matter for overview and
scrutiny so this is on page eight as
well
um the let me see the sick bullet point
around
um requesting the head of property
attend a future meeting to answer
questions if members wish to take that
forwards I believe that that is a
question for overview and scrutiny
um next bullet point down
um I think there were questions raised
around
um supplier risk and I can confirm that
I have received an email from Matt on
this matter I'm happy to circulate that
people are interested this is around the
potential risk that the council has the
suppliers going into liquidation
people want me to circulate that is
there any interest
okay yeah so we can note that down just
for that email to be circulated
stick with me folks uh page 10 parking
member further requested a more detailed
look at parking at a future meeting and
I can confirm that we have a follow-up
audit report from the internal Auditors
coming to our next meeting I believe
it says winter 23 I'm assuming that
means our December meeting yep thank you
um and the final one is on page 12 of
the report there was a discussion about
what happens to audit recommendations
when a follow-up order has been
completed where do those audits go and
one of the suggestions was that we would
keep track of those to make sure even if
they're not necessarily a high priority
of the council for something like Danny
Lotto or they're a difficult
recommendation that may take time to
complete and we've agreed that there
will now be a twice yearly
appendix report coming to governance and
audit that will cover any of those
outstanding recommendations and I think
if I'm if I'm
correct we said we'd go back a year or
two just to check that there was any
that we hadn't missed and they'll now be
included as an appendix I believe in the
internal Auditors report is that correct
on a six month basis on a six monthly
basis that's correct so the reason to go
through that and apologies members this
is slowing the meeting down which which
probably will be a long one anyway but I
want people to know that things that we
discuss and agree are being followed up
and the actions are being completed
okay so moving on to agenda item not
four I'm going to agenda item five which
is risk management so I'm going to ask
Matt to introduce this and then I'll be
inviting councilor Yates under 20.1 to
speak Matt
thank you chair the council monitors and
manages its corporate risks through the
corporate risk register the contents of
the report highlight the high priority
corporate risks and show the
arrangements in place to ensure these
risks are monitored and managed
appropriately the council is dedicated
to a proactive methodology on risk
management and interdepartmental
cooperation on risk strategy to drive
and improve and Synergy risk model and
Landscape
risks have been assessed in respect of a
combination of the likelihood of
something happening and the impact which
arises if it does actually happen risk
management includes identifying and
assessing risks and then responding to
them risk is unavoidable and very
organizer every organization needs to
take action to manage risk in a way
which can justify to a level which is
tolerable the amount of risk which is
judged to be tolerable and justifiable
is the risk appetite the primary member
oversight on risk is provided by
governance and audit committee cabinet
also has a member risk Champion the
leader of the council and portfolio
holder for corporate for performance and
risk who promotes risk management and
its benefits throughout the council
at staff level the high level corporate
risk register is regularly considered by
the corporate management team governance
and audit committee considers changes to
the risk register the reasons for the
changes and the actions being taken to
mitigate the likelihood and impact of
those risks a view is also taken
regarding the extent to which the risks
should be tolerated
the highest scoring risks are identified
at 4.2 of this report where the score is
12 or above and from 4.6 in detail and
in Annex one where lower risks are
identified recommendation is to approve
and review the corporate risk and
discuss the annexed information thank
you
thank you very much Matt uh councilor
Yates would you like to speak
thank you chair
um
so I see my role as
obviously listening to the governance
and all audit committee today I just
want to provide some context as the
portfolio holder on this item
and in particular the corporate risk
register just run through
some of the context from my side on
these items again ask questions
scrutinize me scrutinize them
the right officers not me sorry I'm not
part of this
so cyber security
um there's a future governance and audit
committee meeting which will be
discussing this further homelessness
um there's 1.2 million pounds in the
budget
for the risk of increased spend due to
homelessness and 2.4 million pounds in
the capital budget for a future for your
house I'm happy to say that Foley house
was just uh won an award for the work
they're doing so um that's great to see
um burst four and five there's a there's
a bigger piece of work being done on the
project management framework
um uh the environment act so
this keeps getting pushed back and
there's no strict time frames on the
environment act I believe it's going to
be discussed after the next general
election
um uh Net Zero strategy so
it's important to say there's no
guaranteed external funding for this we
are budgeting for electric vehicles
um electric charging stations however
and we are going to apply for funds to
decarbonize our estate however we have
to apply for that funding it's not
something that's given from government
and there is a risk that we won't
receive that funding so
it's worth making that note so I just
wanted to highlight that at a high level
and thank you for your time
thank you Council Yates do members have
any comments they would wish to make
welcome councilor packman
apologies for my lateness
no if nobody's going to make yeah no buy
one's Christian just very quickly when
we're talking about the Net Zero
strategy and the
um
the decarbonization of our owner States
regardless of whether we get the grants
if there are repairs being made are we
going with a net zero strategy on things
like ongoing repairs that obviously come
out of existing funds
um we're looking for sustainable
long-term solutions for everything that
we're doing at the moment particularly
so for giving this building for example
we know that the boilers need to be
replaced they're coming to the end of
their life
we would not be able to meet our Net
Zero objectives if we were to replace
them directly with just gas boilers so
whatever we do with this building needs
to be on
um with them you know with the minds
I've actually hitting on Net Zero Target
I've got um it might be better if Bob
Porter is available possibly to speak
because obviously with them
Bob's Rema is the property department so
I don't know if there's anything you can
talk about your team's sort of and
housing approach to repairs and
maintenance across our portfolio and how
we sort of consider Net Zero in our sort
of ongoing daily repairs and maintenance
work
yeah yeah sure so um
the stock that has this dock stop to
start with obviously we do we do have a
journey to Net Zero strategy which has
been
um through cabinet and adopted which
talks about the approach to
decarbonizing the housing stock
um and um I mean to start with we're
currently in the strategy is about
investing in the fabric of buildings
first so improving thermal insulation
and thermal performance of buildings and
then moving on to decarbonizing space
and water heating as Technologies
develop
um you know there's there's quite a lot
of stuff in the media isn't there about
replacing gas boilers with air source
heat pumps for domestic use
um I think that the headline message
from from
um from myself and from the housing
service is that only works in dwellings
that have proper insulation and
um you know can effectively manage with
the lower heat output the air source
heat pumps
um generate
um so um so that's the approach and as
far as the gas contract is concerned
which is probably the key thing in terms
of space and water heating
um the current gas contract has got a
replacement of gas boilers only on
failure and in the previous contract we
had
um
a planned maintenance kind of renewal
program
um
replacing gas boilers at the predicted
end of life but now we're only replacing
gas boilers on failure and we will move
um where later in the 2020s I think from
2028 onwards we'll remove we'll move
towards a large-scale replacement of gas
boilers with Alternative forms of
heating
the other thing to say on
decarbonization of the housing stock is
you probably will have seen the reports
uh in relation to the tower block
refurbishment programs
um so five tower blocks in that program
we've got a combination of building
safety funding for the replace removal
and replacement of external wall
insulation
um partly for fire regulation purposes
but also we're taking the opportunity to
upgrade that insulation and increase the
thermal efficiency of those blocks but
we've also got money from the social
housing decarbonization fund for
um for Works to
improve the the EPC ratings of those
buildings and reduce the carbon
emissions related to those buildings as
well so as well as the increase in
thermal insulation we will be replacing
space heating we're working on
ventilation and we're doing General
upgrades and overhauls of the blocks as
well so that is going to make a
significant impact on the carbon
emissions for the housing stock as far
as the corporate state is concerned I
think Mr blundell's always already
referenced us looking at some of our
major corporate buildings and this
building included we are commissioning
retrofit study for this building to
seat to look for recommendations about
how we can best approach decarbonization
of this building and we'll be looking
for opportunities to bid for funding
from the public sector globalization
fund for the corporate State as well so
hopefully that that's helpful
thank you
thank you very much
um I've got a few questions just to ask
on this the risk register is not the
item that was just being covered
um on page 31 the summary of the various
scores
um
I can see how we got to each of the
schools I can't in my own head work out
how a Cyber attack would be the same
impact and likelihood
as the environmental act or Net Zero
strategy so I wanted to understand
whether how we're making those
determinations so I can see
on page 29. how the comparisons are
being made around impact so we're
looking at in all three of those items
it would be severe
but are we really saying that the
reputational impact of
um not
um at the Regulatory and the compliance
impact of not implementing Net Zero in
the correct time scales is the same
impact as if the council
had a Cyber attack that we have seen or
the like the likes of which we've seen
in the sector because to me the impact
of that on the ability of the council to
deliver its strategic priorities and
Service delivery and reputation is
clearly higher
um so I I can't quite see how the
scoring works and I'd just be interested
to understand a bit more about how we've
got to that point um Chris yes
um so you'll see obviously within the
report the headings across the different
types of risk that their the impacts are
assessed against and we consider when
allocating the score the highest score
from any one of those categories so I
think as you rightly say there are
um
there have been instances where
authorities have been subject to cyber
attacks but they're effectively they are
incapacitated that there's they're
unable to act
um
for a period of time and then there are
long-lasting effects after that as well
I think it's I understand what you're
saying in terms of
um some risk being
um
more severe than others
and making that comparison between them
it can be difficult I think when they're
hitting different categories of risk so
um a Financial Risk could be considered
severe but could have very uh might not
have you know long lasting strategic or
reputational impacts on the authority
whereas something like uh Net Zero for
example we know will have significant
impacts on us from a service delivery
um impact just to pick on a minor what
one might consider relatively minor
thing discussions I was having with Mike
cumber and wider corporate management
team this week for saying if we were to
move to electric vehicles for our refuse
Fleet they actually need larger spaces
between each vehicle because of the
risks associated with the batteries that
they hold because that they're a fire
risk to each other
we don't have the capacity when our
Depot at the moment to house enough
vehicles and
um and to their to accommodate them all
within the current footprint of the
depot so although that might seem
something that's relatively minor that
would have significant impact on Service
delivery if we weren't able to address
that because ultimately we wouldn't be
able to get our
um all our rounds out on a timely manner
to service all the household collections
across the um the cost of the district I
think it's a very long-winded way of me
saying
although they might be picking up same
scorings they have got a different risk
composition because they're probably
hitting high scores across those
different risk categories
but perhaps something we can discuss
um outside of this meeting I understand
there might be something a little bit
more color we can bring to the report in
order to present
um
where those high scoring risks are
hitting those different types of
categories so it's presented to members
that although they've got the same
scores it might be hitting more risks at
a high level rather being in one
particular isolated category
thank you I appreciate that and just to
there's a bit of a riff off of that um
one of one of the ones that I wanted to
understand a bit better on page 40 we
have the emerging risk or I can't
remember the exact language apologies
um current risk this one is sorry of a
major emergency where the impact is a
three now I can understand
um because there's a real problem with
how organizations deal with uh high
impact low probability events it's a
reason why most organizations didn't
have a pandemic on the wrist register
because it seemed as so unlikely your
risk register can be dominated by these
high impact but I can't I can't see how
a major emergency I mean maybe I'm
misunderstanding the terminology behind
that how a major emergency and it's
referencing you know the impact of
um covet how that could be anything
other than an impact and particularly
when you start to compare that to you
know the points you've just gone through
around
um
uh you know the impact on service levels
I I I think there's a there's maybe
again as I said as you said and I think
I agree with maybe there is more flavor
we can bring to those but I I that's a
point that I sort of keep bumping up
against is how something that could
impact life could impact
um some of the council in such a severe
way would have a low probability
absolutely but why why has it got a
lower impact than some of the other
risks that we're seeing on the on the
risk register I asked the very same
question actually when this was
presented in front of me
um
what it's worth bearing in mind is this
is the score after mitigation and
because these major emergencies have
become
um quite frequent actually in recent
times so we've almost seem to be in a
state of Perma crisis that we've got
better skilled at responding to these
emergencies and have quite detailed
emergency response plans there are Mike
humber's the director that's responsible
for emergency planning so I'm sure he
can respond to you with a bit more
detail and color than I can on that one
thank you Chris um yeah as as Chris has
said we you know we plan and exercise
for emergencies of all sorts of uh uh
you know size around the district and
um
I think
hello major emergency that there are
there are some emergencies that are more
significant than others um some last
longer than others some require a mutual
aid from other authorities other
organizations and some are multi-agency
and some are just us
um I think this it's also important to
look at the the red text on here which
is about a a slightly new situation in
that the Kent resilience team that
support the emergency
um response and and kind of coordinate
us with the other
um districts in in the county there are
changes going on there and the amount of
support being provided is reducing and
that itself creates a risk and I think
that's you know that's an important
element of this of this um this item
here and and that it's um it's now
included as a with a score nine
um because that's a an emerging
situation and something that we need to
respond to to make sure that we still
have
the right amount of resource to be able
to respond in the way that we do which
is fairly well to to you know these sort
of District level emergencies that occur
okay and then just as a follow-up
um is there a piece of this that the
committee is not seeing and shouldn't
see around how operational risks are
being dealt with around emergency
response and business continuity so
we're obviously looking at a lot of the
corporate risks how they'll impact
Service delivery but I'm assuming that
under business continuity or under
emergency planning there's going to be
those operational risk being impacts
like impact on life and is that why
we're not seeing it on the corporate
risk register as well
um
I think that's a that's a good question
um I think it's something we probably
need to review and and bring back
actually because you're right that
you know some of the
you know some of the risks and some of
the some of the activity is probably not
it's probably not to
um not included here
um I mean I think yeah that the
emergency planning Community there's an
extremely there's a lot of activity that
goes on
um you know we're a member of the Kemp
resilience Forum
um you know we use a system called
resilience direct with a huge amount of
information held in there but it's yeah
I think it's probably something to take
away and look at whether we need to
provide a little bit more information
here happy to happy to take that away
and look at it okay and it's just out of
Interest I don't think we want the
um risk ready to be fooled to be full of
high impact low probability events I
think this is for our purposes but just
in terms of assurance that that process
is happening I know this is going to be
picked up it's not on this calendar of
Intel and audits but I'm hoping it will
be picked up in the future I think it
got delayed from this year's I'm looking
at you but I apologize I think if I
remember from the last meeting it got
delayed into the next year but just with
that point around losing that um
involvement or as much as it was with
the Kent resilience team I just wonder
if that might be something we could look
at
thank you
and then apologies another one
um
I think this has been picked up but
again I wanted to clarify
we've got no change in the health and
safety score
but later in the agenda the next agenda
item nine actually we then have a low
Assurance I'm assuming that some of the
risk is being picked up because we've
now created a new risk around first aid
which seemed to be a big chunk of
the I mean we'll hear from from
Christine and Simon later
um So within the appendix to the risk
report there are some new risks that
have been added and largely in response
to that order
um it's probably I don't know still
um Christian Simon's thunder in terms of
that actual updates and responding to
that but there has been a detailed
management plan that's been produced off
the back of that internal audit and last
night's overview and scrutiny approved
the health and safety well-being policy
that were there from there and I go on
to Cabinet to approve so that's all sort
of reflecting the work that we're doing
to address the recommendations that have
been
um raised by internal and some of the
content on the in the annex reflects
those new risks that have presented as
part of as the outcome of part of the
audit
thank you we welcome those changes thank
you
um do any other members have any
comments yes councilor Davis thanks
chair
um I'd just like to uh say how pleased
I'm see the resilience regarding cyber
attacks because it's it's an invisible
threat a lot at the time and obviously
when it happens you don't necessarily
want to advertise it
um I can't help but think that we've got
a lot of mitigation going on with regard
to mental health for people working at
home we've got mitigation for their
working environment and although we
discussed it overview and scrutiny
visually assessing their work
environment that's not the same as a as
a robust you know even down to the
condition of the chair for instance that
they sit on and that could I perhaps
implore this Council to look at
coming back a little more to in-house
working rather than everybody working
remotely because that would also
mitigate a lot of the risk of Cyber
attack because obviously if everybody's
working remotely a catastrophic Cyber
attack can grind things to a halt if
we've got a more office-based situation
and I think it would mitigate some of
the costs particularly in terms of
employee welfare and so on
um could I just carry on with a couple
other points or did you thank you
um also councilor Yates mentioned the
ongoing situation with uh one of my
favorite topics birth four and five
um
couple of questions because I understand
that we have an open-ended situation and
and every time we speak there seem to be
more questions raised than than not but
then answered uh are we still paying
Brett's compensation because the report
says that the final completion of the
birth was September this year it's taken
a year to put electrics on it which I
don't believe we're on the old one so
maybe let's not argue about whether
that's an upgrade however are we still
paying them and what is the time frame
because there's no application from
Brett's for superstructure that they
claim to need on this to unload and
they're discharging directly onto the
key side we've basically spent several
million pounds on a big floating pontoon
that they more up to and don't use for
anything other than that
um what is the time frame how much more
is to be spent because there's no final
budget and I'm aware that there was
extra money spent this year towards the
electrical supply and that well that was
in the original spec and brief why was
it not done why are we paying out
compensation 12 months on
[Music]
um
so thank you very much yeah oh and one
other point by the way there is a
problem with the Inner Harbor flap gate
at the moment
many of us believe that had substantial
repairs done to it twice in the last
five years perhaps um we could have an
answer on that because uh I believe it
was a Dutch company that were last
involved that did a substantial
restoration on it a couple of years ago
and if there's a problem now why is that
because it was signed off and surely two
years after spending six seven figures
on it we shouldn't be back in the same
position
thank you I think he councilor Davis um
before I pass over to officers I just
want to on the points you rate around
verse four and five on your last point
there I do think the appropriate place
to raise that is at the cabinet or via
overview and scrutiny we have to focus
on process here and some of the points
there and that is why I did wonder and
sorry I know I sometimes digress but
they they're obviously all sensor links
yeah certainly some questions around
birth birthday may come up later in the
agenda so you may want to question there
but I don't think it's appropriate for
officers to have to answer for maybe
political decisions that have been taken
and the appropriate Place may be cabinet
or overview I wasn't talking about the
political side I was talking about the
delivery side and why we've had these
delays because again there was a lot of
discussion years ago
um where the cap the council we implored
them to look at the situation because it
was quite clear that the environmental
impact assessment would be needed
the change in Project program following
the notification has resulted in
Financial Risk to the council nobody set
out to do that had that been included
and accepted and if it was blatantly
obvious to community activists it should
have been obvious to those responsible
so and we're still paying out for this
so okay I think I'm sorry sorry no no no
I think it's fine officers will be
answered I'm sure some of some of your
concerns but I just want to make you
aware that some of the stuff won't
necessarily be able to be covered Chris
do you want to come in on the return to
work and and the other aspects thank you
in terms of return to work
um some valid points have been raised
there and they'll be addressed as part
of our trying to think the right name of
the policy it's not quite flexible
working because that's actually a piece
of legislation that we have to adhere to
but there'll be a hybrid remote working
policy that actually has to come to
general purpose committee to approve
that so members will have the ability to
shape influence and ultimately prove
that policy that will inform how
officers work you know whether it's
remotely in the office those proportions
and
um the concerns that you raise will be
addressed as part of that policy
in terms of the financials on birth four
five I think
um chairs right it's appropriate for the
cost of the scheme to be reported to
cabinets part of our standard
um Financial monitoring
um reporting I wouldn't want to be
saying anything uh that is ahead of our
our standard reporting and also May uh
Prejudice any sort of ongoing discussion
negotiations that are going on uh with
Brett's around the final costings of
that so
um
unless there's anything else that you
wanted to be addressed here I know I
think that covers it
um I had councilor freaky you indicated
um if I could just ask a process
question I wasn't absolutely clear if we
were following in terms of governance in
order to recognize national standards
when we were coming up with for example
those impact comparisons or whether it
was which is what I assumed initially
but from this conversation I'm wondering
is it something more tailored to our
district
it's so it's it's the it says in the
report let's try and find the right
section it's before the table comes in
yeah it's the orange book which is a
government
um source of guidance in terms of risk
management that's the framework that we
follow uh try and find I always find it
maximum for me yeah the government's
orange book on risk management States
risk management shall be an essential
part of governance and Leadership and
fundamental how the organization is
directed managed and controlled at all
levels there's a link in the report that
takes you through to that framework
that's what we followed when we
implemented our new risk management
policy because the policy is tailored so
it's specific to fanet because
government obviously is a very wide
spectrum of different sizes nature of
organization so we've followed
their overall framework but tailored it
through our risk management strategy
trying to think the last time we brought
the risk management strategy probably a
year or so
okay
18 months ago was the last time it came
um but happy if you if it's something
the committee wanted to bring the the
strategy
um to a future meeting for you to have
sight of it given that they have the
risk management reports presented to
them could just be appended for comment
yeah
take the next step
no thank you
okay uh councilor I'm gonna let you come
back in no the rules in the Committees
and people can speak once but I'm happy
for you to have a clarification I just
wanted to thanks Cheryl I was just
wanted to clarify because I had
mentioned the flat Gates but your
feedback in terms of addressing the
cabinet does that apply to that project
as well then yeah okay thanks sorry
Justin
okay members we are
um asked the recommendation is to
approve the review of corporate risks
and discuss Annex risk I think we have
discussed them can I have a proposer to
approve the review
councilor Donaldson the seconder
councilor britcher
we all agreed on that
agreed
so I have committed the Cardinal Cinema
chair of speaking so much about the
minutes I forgot to actually prove them
so now we actually have to go back to
agenda item three
um can I have a proposer to uh approve
the minutes please councilor britcher
and a seconder please
yeah thank you very much
okay all those in favor
agreed okay now we can move on
so now if you are tracking how this
meeting is going we are going from
agenda item five to back to three and
now we're going to nine
so
um for those members councilor packman
you came late we have a member speaking
on the 20.1 so we decided to bring
forward a couple of the agenda items so
we are now on agenda item nine I'm going
to ask Christine to
um
maybe it's Christina you know Simon to
um provide us with the report and then
I'm going to bring in councilor Yates
speaking on a 20.1 Simon over to you
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quickly internal
audit update report which summarizes the
work undertaken on your behalf by The
Escape audit partnership since the last
meeting of this committee did also to
contains details of the performance of
these Kent audit partnership up until
the end of quarter one on 30th of June
if I could um direct your attention to
the table on page 85 of the agenda pack
that lists the seven sorry the nine
audits completed during this period very
busy quarter for us so of those nine new
audits which we completed we were
pleased to conclude substantial
Assurance in three areas those being
Garden waste and recycling income the
HRA business plan and also insurance and
infantry supportable assets
in the area of Environmental Protection
Service requests we concluded reasonable
assurance
rent accounting collection and debt
management was largely reasonable
Assurance although we did include
partially limited and that was in the
area of debt management and Recovery
particularly pertaining to large former
debts
um
related to formal tenants
the eks data management desegregation
project splitting up ICT
from the three Partners or the three
former partners we could only conclude
limited Assurance in that area at this
time
employee health and safety a very
important area
and has been touched on uh slightly
through the previous agenda item in
terms of the risk register I'm afraid we
concluded limited Assurance in that area
at this time management have committed
to a detailed action plan and obviously
we will be revisiting that as part of
the follow-up process
the final two areas we concluded no
Assurance uh not something that we like
doing
and we don't often conclude no Assurance
planned maintenance contract letting and
management I'm afraid we concluded no
Assurance in that area and that was also
the case with East Kent opportunities
um as is the case normally with this
report the vast body of the report
details uh with um bullet points why we
have concluded each of those Assurance
areas in respect of each audit area
as I've said a previous committee
meetings an important part of internal
audit work is follow-up when we conclude
a audit review we agree with management
and action plan for improvement in terms
of recommendations we then go back
typically three to six months later
check what management have done in terms
of implementing those recommendations
and in terms of the critical and the
high recommendations we test to make
sure that they have been implemented
During the period under review we can
complete it three follow-ups and they're
detailed on page 99 of the agenda pack
vat was already reasonable and all the
recommendations have been implemented we
very rarely move from reasonable to
substantial at the time of follow-up
simply because we don't do enough work
and enough testing really to justify
that level of increase
complaints monitoring very pleased with
the Improvement there from no Assurance
up to reasonable
um
very significant Improvement by
Management in that area
absence management unfortunately there
has been slippage in the implementation
of the recommendations
as part of that all get we covered
um
sickness leave unfortunately that was
limited Assurance flexi time recording
which was also limited the reasonable
was for the recording and management of
annual leave
and those Assurance levels remain
unchanged after follow-up we do have
management response there from the head
of HR
in terms of the annexes to the report
appendix one on page 102 is progress
against the plan so that shows you where
we are against the agree 23 24 plan as
at 30th of June we had completed 23
against the target of 25 so very much On
Target and that continues to be the case
in July and August
appendix 2 contains the definitions of
what we mean by substantial reasonable
limited to no Assurance they are sip for
definitions
um and also the definitions of the
critical high medium and low priority
recommendations that we make as part of
audits
appendix 3 on page uh 106 is uh those
recommendations are still outstanding
after follow-up so those are the
recommendations listed in the table on
page 99
and shown as still outstanding you get
the full detail of the recommendations
in appendix 3.
appendix 4 keeps in view those audits
that are limited or no assurance that we
still need to go back and follow up we
diarize those based upon the agreed
implementation dates for the
recommendations so they will be coming
forward to Future meetings of this
committee and last but not least is a
balanced scorecard of key performance
indicators for the Eastgate audit
partnership itself broken down into four
parts
Innovation and learning customer
perspective Financial perspective and
internal processes
um probably the key
kpi on there is the one that I mentioned
which is completion of the audit plan
and as I say as at the end of 30th of
June we have completed 23 so we're well
on target
um
happy um chair to take any questions
members may have on any item within the
report thank you
thank you very much Council the AC on
speaker 21.
thank you chair
um as the relevant cabinet portfolio
holder
um welcome these audit findings and I
believe we'll be using them and to
improve as an organization I just want
to
add some context to two of the items
highlighted in the report on top of the
management response in the audit
findings and that's um
the health and safety and limited
assurance
and the Eastern opportunity no Assurance
so firstly on employee health and safety
is my my background in offshore wind
where I uh sat on our health and safety
committee I saw within that committee we
carried out investigations we
've used the statistics of the
organization and made recommendations so
I completely understand
the outcome of this and since becoming
Cabinet member of this term
um we've had fortnightly meetings with
the section 151 and health and safety
manager
and as part of that we are as a Cabinet
also reviewing health and safety
statistics
um and uh
um what I'm
what I want to highlight is that
following these audit findings we will
be reviewing
um at that for now be meeting the
detailed action plan
um setting out how TDC will address all
the points raised by the audit and the
time scales for doing so
um so that's on employee health and
safety on Eskin opportunities I've I've
been appointed onto the board of Eastern
opportunities Eko and we'll be raising
um
points the next board meeting I want to
make my position clear that if I feel
like we as an organization for residents
are not getting good value getting good
value for money
or the money can be saved by making
actions that do not jeopardize the
projects then actions will be taken to
address this
um
especially as the Eco Eko board is due
to wind up soon
um I do not want more taxpayers money to
be used whereas there is not clear value
for money so I just want to make that
clear thank you
Council Yates I'll open this up to
members does anybody wish to speak on
this and add comment
well I will get us started I just sorry
Christian again
um I just want to note a couple of
things
um there's been quite a few discussions
at the uh the the pre-meat we had for
governance and audit and subsequently
about the amount of no or limited
Assurance audits that are coming back we
seem to have quite a regular run of
these now
you know some of this is clearly going
to relate to Historic governance
problems and historic management issues
um but I would be I'm not going to ask
anybody if their opinion at the moment
but I would just from from the officer's
perspective because I think we need to
keep track of this but I understand that
officers will be bringing a report to
October's cabinet meeting specifically
on this issue so I wanted members to be
aware of that and look out for it
um because I think this issue does need
to be monitored we as a committee need
to keep monitoring it if we keep getting
limited or no Assurance all that's
coming back then we may need to take
action as a committee to keep flagging
these things up because in many ways we
may be seeing a lag in the data that
we're seeing historic issues where
policies haven't been updated or
processes haven't been monitored the way
they normally would have done for a few
years because Focus was elsewhere
because of covert or because of
management changes if that continues
then we may need to continue to flag
this up because that should be being
sorted out over time so I just wanted to
raise that comment and update members
councilor bright did you want to come in
um
item 2.5 which is on page 90.
um a quick question about the writing of
off of debts
um
what's the process for deciding on
when and how much debt is written off so
who actually makes that call
serve our different Arrangements set out
in our Constitution that specify who
needs to be involved in debt write-offs
at a certain level they need to be
presented to cabinet
below that I can sign them off and
as it says this to have been some
instances where the Constitution process
having the right person sign them up
hasn't been followed it's a conversation
that I'm
a ranging tab with the bobbin his income
management team to make sure that the
process going forward is uh in
accordance and align with our
constitution requirements but um quite
often even when uh a debt is written off
um
even
across our whole income Spectrum so not
just runs you might be talking about
council tax uh business rates or other
sundry debt
um that's actually just an accounting
um Arrangement where we need to remove
that debt from our balance sheet because
it's highly unlikely that we're going to
receive and recover that income that
doesn't mean that recovery action will
stop
um so for example on uh council tax
there's a set of which I
um which is an area that I oversee there
there's a a set procedure where we set
out
um and send out to Residents reminder
letters in terms of if they're behind or
in arrears on their council tax to get a
couple of reminders letters then we send
them further communication that
effectively notifying them that recovery
action will be taken if they don't make
a payment by a certain date with a
follow-up reminder after that and only
after that point as the court summons
issued to an individual if they're not
um cleared the debt on their council tax
account
great I fully understand why we have to
write debts off at times that's it's the
same in all areas of business I guess
where I'm going to this is the point you
raised about fixing the processes
because that's why we're here right
we're here to make sure that processes
are being adhered to
due process has been followed and we're
clear on on areas of governance so if
you can give us Assurance in in future
meetings that that that's been idea to
and follow that would be great thanks
Matt
sorry Matt yeah I mean I can certainly I
know that it is across what uh large
areas of our organization as I said I
spoke to in terms of council tax and
there is a process where we
um where the service manager can write
off a debt to a certain level then it
comes to me and then I have to have
conversations with Robin if it's of a
certain level it goes to cabinet so it's
not something that I have concerns that
is widespread across the organization
clearly there's an instance in relation
to rent accounts where there's been some
uh rent bad debts that have been written
off
um that not in a line with sort of our
Constitution doesn't mean necessarily
that was the wrong decision which means
it hasn't had the right approvals and as
I said earlier that's something I'll be
speaking with Bob about and his team to
make sure that we can just get that
tidied up and aligned with
um policy and procedure across the rest
of the organization
thank you um going on now to page 94
around the planned maintenance contract
letting and management where we've got
no Assurance again it looks like a
process thing so due process not not
being followed when it comes to
creating contracts
um do you want to talk about about that
because again I think we need to be
really sure here that when we employ
employing companies or third-party
contractors that we're
we're being absolutely transparent and
following due process
sure
um
uh Bob's Port has provided a management
response to this and vitamin in the
second just in terms of this this
contract and uh particular I think
um it's worth noting some of the
um individual
um recommendations and shortcomings in
the contract itself particularly around
the clock at work were terms that were
inherited from East Kent housing because
the contract was let under their terms
and conditions
um however there clearly have been some
instances where contract management
controls haven't been as robust as we
need them to be that has clearly been
identified as part of the internal audit
and I know that
um Bob and his team have been working on
an action plan to address
um those
um those shortcomings but Bob if it's
okay I'll invite you in now to speak to
that
yes thank you
um I mean primarily this this audit
looked at two contracts
um although there were some others
considered as well one of those was the
planned
um external decorations contracts and
the other one was a gas servicing and
compliance contracts
um so um
Mr blunder is correct in saying that the
structure of the contract for external
works is not a structure that we would
use now it was a structure that we'd
inherited from East Kent housing and the
decision to include clarka Works
functions within the con main contract
and it doesn't seem like a sensible
approach and we certainly wouldn't do
that now and I think actually this audit
has
um you know taught us quite a lot about
how we could go about that
um so um following the audit that
particular contract had no more Works
issued on it and it has now ended
because it was due to end in September
23 but no no Works were issued following
following the audit because of those
shortcomings in the contract
structure and we have commissioned a
full re-measure of everything that was
done under that contract there is still
some reconciliation to do with the
outgoing contractor but obviously we
will pursue that
in in detail to ensure that it all gets
properly reconciled
um there's a there's a comment in here
about the time scales of procurements
that related specifically to the gas
contract
um you know obviously
we could always do with more time in all
of these things but I am pleased to be
able to tell you all that that contract
was
procured in a compliant way on time and
let and mobilized on time and actually
our new guests contractor is performing
very well so we're really pleased with
that
um we have also let a new contract for
compliance Works to support us
what we've called technical auditing
effectively so
where our main compliance contractors
are undertaking compliance checks and
compliance Works a sample of those is
now checked by the new
um technical auditing contractor so for
example
the gas contractor visits the property
and
Services the boiler and gives us the gas
level gas safety record saying
everything's fine we're entirely reliant
on that guest engineer for the accuracy
of that certificate so a proportion of
those now are checked by a third party
contractor to give us assurance
that they're being done properly and
we've applied that approach across our
other compliance work streams as well
um and I think one of the other key
things here is about post-inspection of
Works in these contracts and we have
done quite a lot of work with the plan
maintenance team to introduce new post
inspection
regimes so that a proportion of jobs are
post-inspected
um
so um I mean I think they're the
headlines
overall I think uh the the the audit has
been really helpful in identifying areas
that we can tighten up and improve as I
said at the beginning did it only it did
specifically look at two contracts so
um
I although there are lessons to learn
about from this across the whole program
we've also got some examples where I
think there are there was good practice
in place as well so
um you know so um
I think probably the last thing to say
is that the action plan we have had the
follow-up audit
um we haven't seen the report of that
yet but we've provided all the evidence
for the follow-up order and a large part
of that the action plan has been
actioned and implemented
um so you know moving the service
forward to to manage these things more
effectively
thank you that's really clear so it's
really encouraging that
whilst this isn't necessarily good
you're taking the actions it's Legacy
issues we're moving on and and we should
see improved scores in the future
thank you
thank you um I have a question for you
Simon around the East Kent opportunities
audit
um there's some very
um I would guess carefully chosen
language there that I wanted to
understand a little bit more
um so in 2008
states that the TBC contributed
stamp Duty value of 4.5 million in cash
of 400 000 and then
is estimating or forecasting the TVC and
I'm sure that's not your estimate
um could have received total
disinvestments of around 1.8 million
from the land
and cash value at 4.5 million in 2008
when it was put into
can you see can you just expand on that
sentence a little bit because I I didn't
I didn't fully understand what um return
Planet teacher councils expected or
forecasted to get from that
um and whether that's like for like cash
for land or or whether there's something
else and that word could have received
total disbursements I just wonder have
we refused any is that why the word
could's there or is it because it's a
forecast
so in terms of The Wider conversations
about Eko the original premise that Ikea
was set up was as effectively
regeneration and economic development it
was never about return on investment a
large proportion of the money that was
invested within Eko when it's talking
about the the values was to unlock the
spine Road and the access through the
district so a large chunk of the
contribution that you know the receipt
that would have been generated as a
result of the original investment
effectively was reinvested as part of
that spine Road activity so what what
this doesn't take into consideration uh
as an audit which is because it's
looking specifically at you know Eko and
how it's performing what we put in what
we got out it doesn't look at the wider
economic benefits to the district and
I've agreed to do a separate piece of
work to try and understand what those
wider economic benefits were so how much
have we generated in business rates for
example as a result of the developments
that took place as a result of Eko and
the spine road going in and freeing up
the districts a little bit so that's a
wider piece of work that I've now got to
undertake to try and understand and
those you know those large-scale
benefits that are being derived
[Music]
thank you and then On a related matter
but not directly on that I am assuming
that the attack the fact that over the
last five years audit recommendations
haven't been implemented is partly
because this is arm's length and that
there are other partners involved in Eko
so this is the ability to influence it
isn't completely under the council's
control
um partly but I think I'd be passing the
buck to say that's
um that that's it in its entirety
um Matt is currently a member of the
boards which is in a response to a
recommendation from ecap that I
shouldn't be a member of the board which
is accepted due to a
requirement for me as section 151
officer to be able to take a more of a
arms length view of Eko
um I only sat on the board for one or
two meetings itself prior to that it was
attended by the previous chief executive
so I think
um
there's been a lot of internal and we've
seen this as a theme throughout a lot of
the the reports that you have seen
I can appreciate it must be frustrating
for the committee lots of the reasons
why we have seen uh limited
um uh or no Assurance opinions and
they're not being consistent
implementation of the recommendation has
been because of the high level of
turnover of Senior Management I would
say here since it's another
instance of when that happened when I
received the internal audit report and
these are conversations I've had with
Christine and Simon they have said I
could we could have issued the same
report that we did in 2018 and that for
me is a situation where it's an eye roll
an audible eye roll moment because that
shouldn't be happening and that's
something we're making sure as from the
measures we've been talking about at
this committee to bring
um more consistent and frequent reports
to you in terms of how we're addressing
um outstanding actions after follow-up
so that they don't just drop off into a
black hole because it's really important
that the valley that we can get from
these internal audit recommendations are
harnessed then we we make use of those
recommendations or if we don't there's a
good reason why and the committee has
sight of that and knowledge of
understanding within
um
an acceptable sort of risk tolerance and
we've said around prioritization think
mentioned Planet Lotto is that
acceptable or not then there's the
opportunity for the committee to
consider whether they want to um
escalate it upwards through to cabinet
or Council
sorry that was a bit of an uh a bit of a
tangential response through that that
question but I think this again is
symptomatic of lots of the internal
audits you've seen over the last couple
of committees
and I think there's an acceptance from
the committee I don't think you have
people you know well certainly this is
the second meeting of this Council
overly criticizing what's happened in
the past I think we just want to see
Improvement yeah and I think that's
where you know if
if recommendations are being flagged up
we would expect that follow-up orders
that you know management responses are
strong on that and that over time things
that are being prioritized so I you know
I think I think we can draw a line under
the issue to say we'll see yeah and I
think our job will be to hold you know
collectively officers and cabinets feet
to the fire and make sure that you know
that these recommendations are being
implemented but I appreciate you um
appreciate your comments do any other
members want to come in at this point
yep councilor Davis
um just one point and I'd like to say
thank you for that report Chris as well
and and it's quite clear to some of us
that things are moving even though the
the evidence
um an officer said to me recently that
and described TDC as being like a tanker
that it takes a while to adjust
Direction you're with me and and I think
it was a very good analogy
um an area of concern is for example but
I think Bob may have answered it in uh
on page 95 it refers to contractors
fitting uh low-cost non-direct wired
carbon monoxide alarms in every instance
um 13 new boiler installations and there
were 13 instances with work paid for but
no certification
um to me these flag up things and they
need sitting on because if you or I went
out and did a job for someone with it
and gave them a description and a
contract and didn't deliver it we'd
expect to get arrested for fraud
I understand that this may be one or two
contracts with a much bigger
organization but are we right on top of
this and auditing them properly because
I think in a circumstances like that
everything they touch for a period
should be spot audited I don't say
everything but they should be subject to
spot audits ongoing thank you Council
Davis and to reassure you there will be
a follow-up audit so at the next
committee meeting or maybe the one after
that I'm not sure when next meeting we
will be given a management response did
you want to come in at all Bob
yeah I did so um the uh the gas the the
gas boiler is still certification and
the hard wide
um carbon monoxide alarms they were both
Legacy issues effectively from his Ken
housing setting that contract up
um
the the there was only one price in the
contract for carbon monoxide alarms and
it wasn't clear in that original
documentation whether that was hardwired
or
battery the price to be honest the price
that was in that contract wasn't a price
that was sufficiently higher to be a
hardwired
carbon monoxide alarm hence Eastern
housing had agreed
with the contractor that it would be a
battery operated carbon monoxide alarms
so that's why obviously the new contract
has now resolved that we've moved
because we've moved to a new uh
contractor
um the
the previous gas contracts gas cool
um I mean some of the some of the
certification is mandatory health and
safety related and some of it isn't
um some of and some of it can't be done
at the install it has to be done
afterwards so for example
um the there's a we'd we request a
certificate that confirms that the
contractor has put the appropriate
anti-corrosion additives into the water
within the system
that's not a stature requirement
it's not health and safety requirement
it's a requirement of ours to ensure
that you know the life of that central
heating installation is preserved
um it can't be done on installation it's
completely reliant on the contractor
going back and gaining entry back to
that home subsequently and sometimes
tenants don't let them in so that's why
there was a difficulty with that
um I I think it probably was a mistake
previously to make full payment
um with even with those missing
non-statury certificates
um
so the new Arrangements have resolved
that
um and um we ins we installed we
instigated a partial payment process so
the contracts are effectively paid for
the work they've done the installation
of the boiler which is the bulk of the
cost with a retainer for until complete
documentation is is provided we went
back on everything on the previous
contracts and made sure that all of the
statutory health and safety
documentation had been provided and it
has been and we've got all of that
um the new contract every guest every
gas boiler installation 100 of gas
boiler installations
are
checked by the technical
the technical auditing contractor so all
of those all of those installations are
checked now so I think the the new
Arrangements in the gas contractor much
more robust than they were previously
done thank you thanks Bob because I'm
sure you'll understand that we're
talking about risk of the council and uh
every individual tenant is entitled to a
copy of their gas safety certificate on
an annualized basis I'm not suggesting
it's going to happen but the risk of of
a few of them getting together and just
having a go at the council could put the
council at risk of uh of reputationally
and financially so so it's good to know
that the the statutory certificates are
being issued to them thank you just a
just a footnote to that just to say that
um the tenant lease held a service does
report compliance information so that's
separate to this audit this audit didn't
look at compliance information but it
does report compliance information uh
quarterly to OSP and to cabinet and
we've had 100 gas
um gas certification across the whole
stock
throughout the time that we've had the
in-house service so um you know we do
take that extremely seriously and if
tenants don't let us in to do a gas
safety check we break in to do it
thank you very much Chris did you want
to come in quickly thank you chat yeah
just uh in relation to your comment
councilor Davis about fraud
um we take fraud and Corruption very
seriously at the organization we have um
uh sort of policy or framework in place
where
um if any fraud is identified or
suspected I should say by officers or by
members they can report it to myself or
to mats or through to internal audits or
through a whistleblowing channels
um that our policy is that if any fraud
is reported to us typically we would ask
internal audit to investigate it fully
and promptly and then from then
depending on the outcome of that we
would report it to the police uh
obviously in public session I won't talk
about any specific contract or
suspective fraud here but if there is
something of
um substantial nature we would bring it
to this Committee in uh under private
session
thank you very much Chris it's quite
reassuring
thank you
um so members the recommendation here is
that we received this report
um there is also the option for us to
add any areas or request any changes
to 0.5 of annex one
um
I have one question on this for you
Chris or potentially to Simon bearing in
mind the backdrop we are getting to the
committee regularly having
areas coming all that's coming back to
us with limited or no Assurance are we
confident that the plan for 23 24 and
any discussions you've had about 24 25
is covering the core aspects and the
core areas of the com of um of the
council because we would just want that
assurance that we're finding that across
the board 20 to 30 percent of audits are
coming back
obviously there's we clearly want to
carry on with the plan but we may just
want to reconsider if there are any
areas that haven't been covered recently
but have a direct Service delivery or
financial impact on the council that we
may want to consider them being brought
forward you may have already considered
this I'll put this first to I don't know
who Chris or Simon do you want to pick
this up first
thank you chair
um Christine and I meet with Matt and
with um Chris on a very regular basis to
discuss progress against the plan and
also any potential changes to the plan
um the plan is along alive
document
it can and should move with the emerging
risks facing the council or emerging
opportunities so changes are made as we
become aware of new risks or risks that
have increased in terms of impact or
severity
um
typically we undertake one follow-up for
each audit largely because we don't want
to waste your money keep going back and
saying no you still haven't done it no
you still haven't done it
um there are exceptions to that though
um and on occasion we will go back uh
particularly if it's a very high profile
um area and do a second follow-up
um in terms of the increasing the number
of limited and no assurances I mean yet
um you've seen I think in our annual
group report talked about an
unprecedented level and they are at an
unprecedented level
um not just in thanet though we are
seeing that to a slightly lesser degree
in some of the other Eastgate Partners
um I think as has been mentioned already
this evening previous
issues with governance Arrangements at
this Authority undoubtedly those Legacy
issues are continuing to have a certain
amount of impact as we recover as an
organization from that and put new
management in place and new processes
and procedures in place
so we keep a watch
um and a watching brief on the plan
um
on a regular basis uh in terms of 24 25
typically we start the planning process
around December January that starts with
me meeting with heads of service
directors individually we then obviously
look at the emerging risk register we
look and what we call Horizon scanning
in terms of nationally what risks are
emerging that could face local
government
by about February we take a draft plan
to CMT and then ultimately the 24-25
plan will come to this Committee
in March of next year
and again
it does move the plan it is changed as
things for example Christine undertook
the work on birth four five which was an
unplanned piece of work I would say that
we never deliver exactly the plan that
is delivered in March each year and
quite rightly so because it moves with
the risks
hope that's helpful
interesting as a new member to sort of
understand that process and before I put
you in Chris I think the the the total
number of audits I've looked at in the
last year that have come back limited or
no I've even partial I think was 16. and
when you looked at where they were
coming from the council it was across
the board which is why you know it's
something more systemic
um so you know I hope the the point is
sort of accepted that as we look at the
next like 18 months of audits hopefully
we're going to be covering a wide
breadth of the council and we can see
Improvement but she wanted to make sure
that's covered Chris do you want to add
anything I think Simon's covered that
really really well and
um
I think the only other thing to stress
is how seriously we are taking this at
the corporate management team we are
acutely aware to the issues that
internal audit are present to us and the
fundamental need for us to to improve
the position
um as well as the meeting Simon's sort
of discussed we're looking to set up
with our corporate management team a
subgroup from that will just be a
project a board that just looks at
governance issues that will be sort of
really
focusing on some of the internal audit
recommendations things that come through
from external audit as well so that's
something we're looking to set up and
constitute within the next month or so
and that'll be meeting on a regular
basis and the body of work that that
um that that board considers will be
potentially producing reports that will
be coming that we will present to this
committee as well
thank you very much
okay members so uh we are going to
receive this report can I have a
proposal to receive the report councilor
Davis seconding
counselor Richard everybody agreed that
we have received the report that's good
so we are now moving back to agenda item
four
so a gender item four is quarter one
review 23 24 treasury management an
annual investment strategy I'm going to
pass over to Chris thank you Matt just
had to mention him yeah you
um because I've forgotten I was
introducing this item
um so
um
uh very timely as we had our training on
Treasury management uh prior to this
session for those of you able to attend
it
um as the trainer Janine set out is now
a requirement for us to report on a
costly basis our treasury management
activity so this is one of those uh
quarterly reports so it's setting out
the position in the first three months
of this financial year up to the end of
June you can see some of in the
executive summary some of the key items
that reported there I think the key ones
really to pull out are around our gross
depth position so that's our ultimate
borrowing position so around 20 million
pound not a huge shift as you can see
over compared to the year previously and
our
underlying uh need to borrow to finance
our Capital program is estimated to be
about 60 million pound by the end of the
financial year so you can see that's
quite a sizable sum but that we won't be
uh you as you can see 20 million
Pounders below that figure quite
consider below that so we're using our
investment balances instead of taking on
external debt which is a prudent thing
to be doing at the moment given how high
interest rates at the moment are we
wouldn't be wanting to take debt on
right at this moment of time if anything
we'll be looking to use our own cash
balances for as much as possible and
then as we all hope interest rates
unless you're a net saver yourself hopes
the interest rates that I say this as a
mortgage holder um hoping to see
interest rates drop or I need to
remortgage myself so hopefully once
those interest rates start to drop over
the next couple of years at that point
in time we'd be looking to take debt on
if we needed to do so so
um I won't go through the detail as a
report but happy to take any questions
thank you very much I'm going to start
off and other members may have questions
um it's just a quick one on page 19 of
the report 5.2 it talks about an under
spend of 33.159 million in the general
fund and 4.103 million in the housing
revenue account can you just give us a
bit more detail on what that relates to
yeah so you'll see
um the paragraph underneath that table
sets out that the actual detail is
um is set out and explained for within
our budget monitoring report so that
report went to cabinets a couple of
weeks ago no no Corsa one yeah
um two weeks ago it went to cabinet so
that's got
um the the full detail headlines from
that I think it's fair to say a lot of
it's down to what I would say in sorry
if this is finance jargon incorrect
profiling which really means we put the
budgets in the wrong place to start with
and those budgets have needed to be
slipped into later years so we've loaded
a lot of the budgets up front in because
Capital budgets tend to span a number of
years so if we take the leveling up or
Mark eight town deal projects for for
example a lot of the budgets were put
early on in the program so in 23 324 but
now we know that activity and the actual
spending is going to happen in later
years so the budgets were I would say
incorrectly profiled and
loaded towards the beginning of the
programs when actually we know in
reality they're going to be delivered uh
more laterally and I think there's a
similar Max and probably time anymore
because he's closer to this than I am
there's a similar sort of position in
the HRA where some of their schemes
actually need to be slipped into later
years as well Matt is there anything
more you can add to that
no not really it's exactly that they
just need re-profiling so the actual
budget monitoring report that's taken
has effectively represented what the new
profiles will look like so next time you
get an update in relation to treasury
management the revised budget Position
will move down and therefore the
underspend will be more realistic of
where we are in terms of that new
profile which you don't keep getting
back 50 million under spend 50 million
under spend it will show that it's been
moved into an appropriate year so that
slippage takes place and you see a more
representative position in relation to
where we are with both general fund and
HRA
just to add to that story so we're going
to come back in you're probably thinking
why didn't you get the budgets right in
the first place I think um just talking
to some of the stuff around the regen
projects in particular we didn't have
enough detailed information when we set
the budgets for those schemes so they
were put towards the start in case we
needed to spend them once we got more
information back from our cost
Consultants then we've reprofiled the
budgets to reflect what the improved
information that we've got from them
okay so yeah that that that helps with
the explanation obviously it's still
large amounts but um in the greatest
scheme of things with the reserves
moving it's it you know can be seen
there the question that I just wonder
whether there was any link to the
expected
um delay in rate reviews and whether
there was any relationship with that
amount of money because I know that
there was been discussions about when
that money could be realized and the
monies that we've been holding on to
just in case whether that's related to
that at all there's no relationship no
no all right okay thank you very much do
any other members have questions
or comments on this agenda item nope
okay there you go the training was so
good that everyone understands it
completely so recommendation is that the
governance and Order committee notes and
makes comments appropriate which I've
done this report are we happy to know
this report can I have a proposer
councilor Donaldson secondar
councilor Davis a members agreed
here we go
on to agenda item six indicative
external audit plan 21 22 to 22 23 and
this is over to Matt
yeah the good thing about this one is
I'll do a brief introduction and hand it
off on someone else
um this is this report is effectively
covering the external awarded plan for
21 22 and 22 23 and has been developed
by our appointed auditor which is Grant
Thornton and Nick is in attendance
tonight to talk us through uh the report
thanks Matt so I'll just briefly run you
through the report and then if you've
got any questions I'm happy to take them
so this is our
um this is our indicative audit plan for
both years the reason that it's called
an indicative audit plan is that the
2021 accounts we're hoping to sign
tomorrow until we've signed those we
have further procedures that we need to
do to finalize our audit plan however
our expectation is that this indicative
audit plan will effectively then be
finalized and there won't be any
significant changes to it the audit is
scheduled to take place in October the
slightly unusual thing that is happening
this in this situation is that we're
looking to bring forward the 2223
procedures and get the audit team to
work across both years with a focus of
getting 21 22 done first but also
bringing forward some of that 2223 work
especially in areas for example if we're
testing debtors if we look at 2223s that
as if a debt is no longer there we can
see it's been repaid it will obviously
help us do the testing there so we're
looking to try and
bring forward some efficiencies in terms
of our audit process for 2223 with the
aim of then trying to catch up the
external audits of the financial
statements and that work will begin in
October the audit plan sets out our
approach to the materiality so when we
give an audit opinion we don't say that
it's correct to a pound we say it's
correct to work in a material amount and
the reason for that is basically the
fact that reports need to be provided in
a timely manner and you want a suitable
level of assurance to your accounts so
the materiality that we're expecting to
have would be around 2.7 million and
that's based on previous financial
statements and but we will reassess that
when we get the final statements if it
counts in terms of our risk-based
approach to audit we identify
significant risks and these are the
areas we think are most likely to have
material misstatements in them and in
terms of local Authority accounts there
are some very big numbers in the
accounts and the very large numbers tend
to be in pension liabilities and
property valuations so the council has
HR Council dwellings which have got a
very high valuation of a land and
buildings with a high valuation and also
investment properties so all of those
areas are key areas of audit attention
especially as property valuations are
more complex and variable to market
conditions
so pension liabilities and property
valuations two of the key key
significant risks and the other one is
around management override of controls
and that is around the risk that
management would post journals in the
financial statements that could
potentially create a material
misstatement that isn't because of any
specific factors at the council that is
a presumed risk in all audits because
the expectation is as external Auditors
as we should be skeptical of management
and the risk that they might post
journals to change the financial
statements so there are there
significant risks that we've identified
in terms of new areas of focus for the
audit for the 2223 audit there is some
new auditing standards that we're
required to consider and they relate to
isof315 ISO 315 is about how we
understand controls and the addition to
ISO 315 is that we need to understand
better how it controls impact Financial
controls so we talked about sort of
cyber security so we don't it won't be
so much focused around that but it is
understanding how it controls feed into
the key financial statement controls and
assessing those risks so we will do a
more detailed piece of work this year on
that
um I'm gonna stop there I think and take
any questions you might have on that
agenda writer
thank you very much yes Chris by all
means comical question yeah it's not a
question for Nick just uh um it's a it's
just a little bit more
um just a detail around to Nick
mentioned the materiality limit
appreciate it probably sounds like a
really high number uh when you think
about two million pound it is but what
they're looking there is there something
fundamentally wrong with our accounts is
there something that we've presented
that you would be going hang on a minute
this is really bad
um if you look at trying to find the
right page 13 of their report they also
have something called triviality
um which is 135 000 that might sound
still relatively high but what they're
saying is anything below that they'll
consider trivial anything above that but
below materiality so between over 135
but less than 2 million they'll still
report to the committee if they find
something that's saying a misstatement
effects they think is wrong in their
accounts they report it but they won't
require us myself myself and Matt to
change the accounts without affecting
their opinion so they won't say the
accounts are wrong they'll say we didn't
like this you should have done that and
they'll still report that to you
okay I appreciate that I was going to
raise the fact that uh trivial amount
being said 135 000 yeah good position to
be in I guess
um are there any comments or or
questions from members
no okay we are down to uh note this
report so I can have a proposal that we
note this report please
Council of Hope
and a seconder
of the bridge
thank you very much our members agreed
thank you very much
um so moving on to agenda item seven
audit progress report and sector update
uh to you Matt
and I'm going to do the same thing again
the audit Focus report and sector update
is effectively provided by Grant Fulton
to give us a view of where we are and
what they can do to support us moving
forward so I'll hand over to Nick
kellerwell so he can talk us through the
report thank you
thanks Matt so this report
um sets out two key areas so firstly
it's providing an update around the
audit Market within local government
accounts and then secondly it's some key
sector updates and papers that we think
are useful to this committee so firstly
around the state of the external audit
Market as we've discussed at the
previous committee and probably once
before that there is an audit backlog in
local government Audits and there and
this paper effectively sets out a number
of reports that have been commissioned
by ourselves and by other people within
the sector around why that is the case
from our perspective I think there's
three key areas around why this has
happened one regulator Focus around sort
of the key areas and the significant
risks I mentioned which are very big
values in the account and then if you
then focus on those areas in a large
amount of work there is an awful lot of
work you can do on pension liability and
some valuations but whether or not
that's adding the value to the council
taxpayer in terms of giving that
Assurance is sort of a question mark and
that's something that is being looked at
at the moment and there are
considerations around whether or not the
code will get changed around that issue
the second one is around local audit
capacity and the capacity within the
market and the UK Workforce and that's
not just an issue in the audit sector
but nationally in terms of the national
Workforce and then that same issue also
applies to local authorities that we're
there is also again a pressure in terms
of Workforce in that those areas so
there's there's sort of the issues that
we've got in terms of what's happening
there are quite significant plans that
are sort of being discussed in terms of
what will
happen in terms of those discussions
they are still going on with the
Secretary of State the proposals that we
have heard to date involve potentially
there being a backstop date and the idea
around that would be that there's a
backstop date put in and if audits are
not completed by that date a disclaimer
opinion would be issued one of the key
reasons that is being pushed for
especially in this year is because
there's the new psaa contract and
effectively they want people the
Auditors to start that contract on time
because if they're all if they're
awarding contracts to a new auditor and
the audit is changing then they want
effectively that order to be able to
start doing the work
so in terms of that I think from our
perspective it's good the fact that
something is changing we don't want to
issue any disclaimer opinions and we are
working hard Atlantic District Council
to make sure that does not happen in
this instance
um but we also are pleased that there is
movements within the market in terms of
having a plan to deal with the backlog
of the audits as well as having plans to
potentially change some of the elements
of the code that are causing delays in
the audit Market
um then on page 77 of the pack we have a
page around the procurement and contract
management and this is sort of looking
at the key areas of focus around what
good looks like in terms of procurement
strategies and this is really just for
members to note and to consider in terms
of whether or not the cat whether or not
and there's anything the council can
take forward on this slide 78 looks at
the movements in the the pension
liabilities and local government pension
schemes there have been significant
improvements in terms of that and the
report notes that assets have wrote the
31st of March 2022 had Rose by 28 and
this is having some benefit for councils
in terms of um I suppose treasury
Management in the fact that there is
expected to be lower payments required
on the pension liability going forwards
and then slide 79 looks at Future
sustainability reporting and what might
happen in that area
again I'm happy to take any questions on
this report
but do you want to come in Chris yeah
I'll never miss an opportunity to talk
about her local accounts and their audit
um just something I wanted to just add
to a next sort of explain very well
already so I'm um so I appreciate I
don't know what it is on your your slide
pack but
um page four of Nick's um presentation
there's that table that's under hadn't
delayed publication of audited local
Authority accounts and you can see the
percentage of authorities who aren't
hitting the deadline for publishing
accounts and also for the accounts being
published
um so you can see go back to 1617 95 of
accounts were audited on time
for
2021 it was nine percent a slight
increase to 12 so it it's dramatically
fallen off a cliff Edge which is part
for some of the reasons Nick was talking
about the ironic thing being actually if
you look at 1617 the deadlines were
later and in 1718 they introduced
something called faster close down
because they thought we were all going
to do this quicker and subsequently
nobody has
um so yeah it's part part which is part
of the problem actually
um but very grateful for the work of
Nick and his team I know they've worked
really hard actually to get the backlog
address they've been some specific
issues relating to thanet in relation to
again Legacy issues related to the
previous corporate management team why
they couldn't progress with the previous
um the audit of the 2021 accounts that
are um on the next agenda item
because because of those issues that
were going on Authority effects they
couldn't say whether the accounts were
true or Fair now we've got that out the
way we feel like we've got a really good
plan in place as Nick said dealing with
20 122 and 22 23 at the same time we're
then hopeful that we'll be able to get
23 24 get my years right next this
year's counts this year's account done
in accordance with the statutory
deadline so we've got a plan in place so
this time next year I hope we'll be able
to say we are one of the authorities
that will have their accounts published
and audited on time
thank you and um
yeah I'll add a comment and then I've
just got a quick question the comment is
this is obviously this delay we've
covered it came at a very bad time for
Thana because at the same time we had
serious governance issues so as well as
as having a delay across the sector
which is delayed information coming
through to us is obviously issues in the
background and we certainly don't want
to have any sort of
classification or or language given on
our accounts beyond that that they are
have been effectively audited the
question I had was um you mentioned they
may be putting a backstop in as a date
and looking at your report it seems to
suggest year end
has there been any discussion of a date
at a specific date at this date there
has been discussions but they've not
finalized what it is so I don't really
want to say but our expectation is that
one of the dates will be 31st March 2024
the thing that is unclear is which years
that's going to apply to
because there's obviously there is
audience but there are slap audits where
1819 isn't signed and even 2017-18 isn't
signed so it's about which years they
want that 31st of March date to cover
okay so that's there is potentially some
room for maneuver for thanet but okay
it's certainly something that we want to
um move forward on and it probably
speaks to why members we were asked as a
new Council and lots of fresh faces our
first ever meeting to sign off accounts
from three or four years ago so
um hopefully that gives some context
does anybody have any questions or want
to make any comments
nope okay we are oh yes councilor
Donaldson yeah I think that uh you know
Chris Blundell and uh Nick hello have
doing a fantastic job in Katrina it's
amazing
um and um
I cannot take the credit
um but okay Tracy behind me is the
accountant who's actually pulled the
accounts together all credit is due to
her and to Matt actually so all I did
was stick my name on them
yeah okay thank you all right thanks and
you know I think we um uh all to accept
to prove and adopt this so I'll propose
that please
thank you so you're proposing that we
know because the reports down for noting
so you're happy to propose to note we
have a second please
Council Lagana
thank you very much everybody agreed
agreed okay we're on to the final agenda
item of the evening agenda item eight
audit findings report 2020 21 and I
think we're straight over to you Nick
thank you um so
um this this report was presented at the
last committee however there are some
updates to it and they're put in blue
writing just to try and make it easier
for the committee around it but the
primary reason this paper has been
represented to the committee is that
after the last meeting we were then
finalizing our audit opinion that we
were looking to sign for the 2021
accounts what happened in that period
was we had advice from our technical
team that due to the new code
requirements around value for money
reporting because we had identified more
findings that then needed to go into our
audit opinion we had to wait to this
committee meeting to present what those
findings were and what the impact would
be on the reporting so we've identified
four key recommendations in our value
for Money Report that's going to be
presented I think next month
um at committee and what we're then
required to in our audit opinion is make
reference to those four key
recommendations so in the audit findings
report those four key recommendations
are noted and effectively it's just to
let members know that the opinion is
going to have those elements in it and
then we will then hopefully look to sign
tomorrow at the 2021 accounts
um I wasn't going to go into great
detail about those four key
recommendations because there will be a
separate committee to discuss those
Chris do you want to add something yeah
thank you
um just in terms of sorry not this
report but the report that Nick was
referring to in the valley for money uh
our plan is we've received that we're
going to be producing a a management
action plan in response to that that
we'll be presenting to cabinet which
we're hoping expecting that they will
endorse following which that will then
come back to this committee so not only
will you have the ability to see what
Nick is and the team at Grant Thornton
are recommending but also scrutinize and
make comment on the the action plan for
management to address them but in terms
of the accounts themselves I'll just
pass over to Matt to give an update of
where we are on the 2021 accounts
yeah yeah what I was going to update on
is obviously we've had lots of
conversations about where we are the
backlog of accounts and everything else
and one of the delays that one of the
results of the delays is that we haven't
been able to publish because we haven't
signed off our 2021 accounts we haven't
got a position to present them we hadn't
got ourselves into a position where we
could publish a draft set of 21 22
accounts I'm pleased to say that today
we published our draft set of 21 22
accounts and the inspection period will
open next week which will give members
of the public six weeks in which they
can come in inspect the accounts and any
Associated bills and receipts and
everything else associated with them so
that we can legitimately move forward
with that process so we are gradually we
are making Headway and making vast
improvements so I just wanted to flag
that
thank you very much do members have any
comments they want to wish that they
wish to make
you know so we have two recommendations
here so that the audit findings report
for 2021 a set out is considered
um and in the enlight unlikely event
that minor change would be required I
like that and from an officers report in
the unlikely event that we would want to
make any changes which we haven't so
we'll move on from that
um are members happy that they've
considered this
can I have a proposer
yeah councilor towney a second
councilor Donaldson are we agreed
agreed okay members that will conclude
tonight's proceedings for the governance
and audit committee thank you very much